I do believe that we need to reframe
success we have to make happy we have to
for the [ __ ] sake of so many [ __ ]
millions of people we have to make
success happiness we have to have to
have to have to welcome to these
successful my podcasts today we are in
New York at vaynermedia and we have our
special guest Gary Vaynerchuk Gary thank
you so much for doing this really
excited to be here I I'm very excited to
talk to you about this because you talk
about something a self-awareness right
you say the self-awareness is is the key
yes and my my number one question for
you is how did you become self-aware
like when did that happen for you when
did it all click in you're like this is
who I am this is what I'm here to do and
then you were like nose to the
grindstone with it in some way when I
hear that question what what feels
natural to me is a evolution between 11
and 18 somewhere between four definitely
fourth grade when I had the conviction
and the guts to have weird little
conversations with myself in bed when I
would be anxious about the fact that I
was making this transition to being a
bad student I don't know how to say it
like you know in third grade I got
straight A's and would win in flashcards
because I have good math skills and and
in fourth grade I literally started
getting bad grades and a it didn't come
natural to me anymore like now now I
think my mind was wandering in class so
the ability to just listen and go off of
that to be successful became a problem
because now I was already starting to
think about how to sell baseball cards
to my friends what am I gonna do after
school let me make a joke to make
everybody laugh my brain started to
wander and then it was also around the
time when it was time to actually do
stuff at home like homework and that was
unacceptable cuz I had to play nerf
football and try to sell and video games
and so between that moment and even
right up to senior year of high school
navigating that and understanding like
this is what I'm good at this is what
I'm not good at and then really in high
school
intuitively subconscious
naturally being able to not have to fit
in and not being affected by I mean look
it's really interesting I think anybody
who's listening I
I mean maybe this is a jersey thing but
like everybody made fun of everybody all
the time always that was just the nature
of it yeah right like like you know I
think a lot about what are we doing to
children in our parenting now that make
it so difficult you know and extreme
bullying is very different than getting
made fun of occasionally and so there's
a lot of variables to this but you know
the high school years of like not
worrying about my popularity and valuing
one things that I'm most proud of is
getting DMS and messages from high
school friends today saying man this is
so cool cuz this was always actually you
you literally had the like things
verbatim you had the guts to be friends
with everybody in high school and I was
very proud of that I was very proud of
weirdest kid on the bus I would
I thought fitting in was fitting in with
everybody instead of fitting into like
six people so I wanted to fit in with
the kid that nobody was nice to I wanted
to fit into the kids that were naturally
kind of my core friends who were like
into sports or sports cards I wanted to
fit in with popular kids and that was
easy tube you know I am Who I am
obviously I have people skills but yeah
I was aware that it was unusual how I
was navigating through high school not
going to parties but working being
friends with the weird kids you know not
over pandering to the coolest kids in
our school not being good at grades like
I was playing I was an enigma my whole
life and I think 11 to 18 was when that
manifested and that I would that's a
long-winded answer to that's when I
started understanding myself which is
what I would argue self-awareness was it
was also when I went through wait a
minute I'm not the cutest kid in class
wait a minute I'm not the best athlete
because in second and fourth fifth grade
I in fourth grade I thought it was the
best-looking most athletic kid in my
class and very honestly I think there's
a chance I was but but but that's
because also because your mom was
pumping you up
like I was like like you know I was yes
that and I was competitive and I have
great hand-eye coordination and I
matured slowly so I boyish looks like
yes all those things but it was a great
I was not scared of all the bad stuff
and I think we live in a world right now
where people are scared of the bad stuff
and I believe that that's what leads to
delusion you don't want to face that
you're not the fastest you're not the
best-looking you're not the smartest you
don't want to face that you don't accept
that which leads to a lack of
self-awareness so I'm kind of guessing
that you were a sensitive kid like I
hear yes
you cried a lot you got your feelings by
the way I'm gonna I'm gonna give you a
huge DAP that is the first time that
somebody has said that and it couldn't
be more true I cried constantly from
1980 from 1982 to 1988 and I mean
multiple times a week real crime well
that so that brings me to another
question so you talked about when you
went to work with your dad yes and he
kind of sensed your [ __ ] right yes
you could you could really [ __ ]
right and he and you made a comment on
one of your podcast that there were many
times you were in his office crying yes
what was he doing you know what's funny
him saying to me like you know the
numbers the number or like he never
really my dad doesn't talk a lot so he
wasn't he was a man from the old school
so it wasn't like he sat me down and
said son you know this embellishing or
lying is onyx it wasn't like that it
would be like you know a customer would
walk in and they're like I would try to
sell them a bottle of wine and I was you
wanna talk about not being self-aware
the the audacity that I had as a 14 year
old who looked nine to have a grown up
coming to a liquor store hand them the
bottle of wine that I knew we had this
sell and be like you should buy this and
they would look at me and say well have
you had it and I would say yes with a
straight [ __ ] face and really like
believed it
is pretty ludicrous and what would
happen is he would give me a look and I
could sense like oh I did something
wrong not right even though I
accomplished the goal and very quickly
it came out it started chipping away the
reason I would cry is my dad is tough
you know I would I would be a 15 year
old kid I would work 11 hours like from
7:00 we'd leave the house at 7:00 a.m.
the store you know got there at 8:10 my
dad would do the deposit
I'd have to keep myself busy the store
opened at 9:00 it's now 7:00 p.m. no
lunch break I've worked every minute
this is a child [ __ ] hardcore real
labor and then at like 650 I would go to
my dad and muster up the guts to be like
hey Dad are we going home soon and he
would like bark at me like you know you
know like like like and like that made
me cry like I don't know like it was
like sad like I was like [ __ ] like
[ __ ] this is hard you know like like and
you know the truth is actually I'm
embellishing a little bit there not that
that's that would upset me what made me
cry actually is my dad genuinely did not
treat employees well and I'm really I'm
sensitive to it as I'm saying it right
now he transformed in the way that he
changed my ability to lie I changed his
point of view on employees
he just wasn't nice you know I'd watch
people really work he came from Soviet
Union you know he looked at employees
like not the way like genuinely the
complete opposite of the way I look at
employees like I look at these guys like
I look at them yeah and I just know what
I feel and I feel a sense of
responsibility and my dad genuinely felt
like I'm paying you and [ __ ] work
like [ __ ] you like really and that
really bothered me yeah well I mean the
guy was working for his [ __ ] life I
mean what a break to get out of the
Soviet you need to be able to hear I did
I judged him immensely at the time yeah
I I look there's people that have come
from hard places that don't treat their
employees like [ __ ] so I still judge it
at some level I understand it a lot more
he really feared really feared was
crippled by the notion of people
stealing from him crippled that was a
deal so I don't know if you know this
this is one of the most fascinating
things to talk to Americans about I
don't think Americans actually really
genuinely understand socialism or
communism degree because they can't
I don't blink right everything was
stolen
the government owns everything so
imagine every store and every company is
owned by the government
so I Gary don't own Vayner I'm some
general manager of not compensated in
any way based on its success so now I'm
making a deal with Dustin that he can
come in at night and steal the computers
and sell them on the black market
but kick me some cat everything was
stolen the entire country ran on the
black market I think about what's
illegal in America drugs
relax market guns at some level certain
time but everything that's illegal here
there's on the black market
and everything is over there everything
milk and tile and carpet and chairs and
like it you know people waited 13 years
my parents waited 13 years to get a
phone like 20 years to get on the line
for a refrigerator and 15 for a car and
like you waited seven hours in line for
bread like the when I talk about utter
ridiculousness
of entitlement in America and its
current state $7 coffees you know
complaining about Delta being late by 10
minutes yeah I not only come from a kid
that grew up in America in a very
immigrant household that never bought
anything for anybody about anything I
also come as the byproduct of parents
and stories my entire childhood of
ludicrous [ __ ] that not a person here
can understand right not here in this
room not anybody who's listening go wait
seven hours in line for a piece of bread
and have access to no other food go show
me show me how much you're gonna cry
about not getting as many likes on
Instagram photos well I mean there's
this huge breeding of entitlement
that is going on in the country that is
it's called prosperity it's my empires
fall yeah Rome did it
Genghis Khan did it we're doing it yeah
we are gonna lose China already won this
is this is just watching it play out
right like this is over every little
Chinese kid is way more hungrier than
our little [ __ ] and guess what I say
good I don't want it to be this is my
team's um wearing do you think we
rebounds room no you're up hasn't
rebounded from it we'd beat the [ __ ] out
of them sure no there's no rebounding
cuz it's it's it's the progression of
the game the young hungrier thing wins
and the fatter older thing loses where
the fat or older thing we think somebody
owes a [ __ ] yeah for what why I love it
I I loved losing I love the process
I love merit that's why I love losing I
do believe that some kid in the suburbs
I know who has a single child because of
population control and has parents
driving the [ __ ] out of them to make it
and of course that has all its own
shortcomings too we all know what our
grandparents did to our parents I get it
the question is which one's better we're
very good at sitting in our collective
ivory towers in America judging you know
our parents generation and it was tough
and beating a kid and hitting and all
this ha ha ha ha ha guess what we're
about to [ __ ] lose they don't think
that they can't what's worse
spanking your kid or creating such
delusion that they're depressed for the
rest of their [ __ ] life I don't know
I'm gonna hit a kid instead and of
course everything's a balance but like
you know there's a balance between
beating the [ __ ] out of your child for
real like extreme terrible things that
happen in our society and what my mom
did which was smacked me in the face
when I got out of hand which said [ __ ]
I'm not gonna do that again I don't
wanna get punched again and it was a
punch it was an open-hand slap but it
[ __ ] hurt where did your mom's
positivity come from her natural DNA she
lost her mother at 5 her dad went to
jail when she was 8
ten years she [ __ ] lived in a Soviet
Union it definitely didn't come from her
environment that's interesting well like
we were saying before like there's a lot
of people that grow up with different
environments but their attitude how that
plays out by the way for the record and
I love co-signing my parents perfectly
parented all that [ __ ]
my mom crushed it all time I've
mentioned it eight billion times I
promise you with the natural DNA that I
was given if I was born under a [ __ ]
rock in like [ __ ] a shitty town and
Turkey to like some [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I'd
[ __ ] be here probably with a little
bit more fucked-up [ __ ] and a little bit
less love to give but I'd be here
because I'm optimistic here's one of the
things that I find that that's really
interesting you talk about you have this
natural DNA right that you like your
success is wrapped up in your DNA and
one of the things that I do is I help
people become that want to become
successful really successful so we work
on their mindset we help them build out
the company that they're that they're
building whatever but what's fascinating
about it is you can't instill the want
in a person to do it so you have people
be like hey I want to do this and then
they don't do anything and then you have
other individuals they want it and
they'll do anything that is necessary
there's a division between people that
want for stuff and people who want for
process totally and I think one of the
things I'm trying to figure out is in
the framework that you set that up this
is why I want to change success you're
properly because of the way we all came
up deeming you're creating a system I
assume I'm making some assumptions here
that a level of you know the framework
creates success financially cuz that's
the nature of business right right I
believe that there's a real atomic bomb
that I can drop on society over the next
50 years around actually reframing
success which will then lead to
everybody having the chance to love a
process there's a lot of people who have
the natural DNA to be an all-time
stay-at-home dad but because we haven't
created the framework yet to making a
stay-at-home dad who crushes and raise
three children that go on to do in cred
things as an incredible North Star
yeah of being successful in the same way
that we do a billionaire or an MBA you
know champion or a rapper that wins a
Grammy we don't we have not given macro
permission yet for the people to self I
mean I know employees right now that
worked for me men and I know their wives
that they should be doing reversal that
the man should stay at home and do the
nurturing and the moms the [ __ ] shark
and she's not happy and he's not happy
and the only reason they're doing it is
we have not had a mature enough
conversation around success we have
created so many by the way we talked to
thank God we talked so much more now
about women and minorities and their
thing but like and you know a guy who
deep in his soul thinks he's a nurturing
father and wants to stay home is frowned
upon by his contemporaries friends in
society you you know immediately goes
into old school people thinking he's a
loser and he can't provide and he's
walking out yet he would love that
process there are absolutely people who
do not love the process of building a
business that makes money note I mean
and and and thus they will stop and
start and have micro wins and macro
failures and will never achieve it it is
if a person comes to us and they want to
work with us that's one of the first
questions that we ask them is do they
actually love the process of what they
do because if they don't they'll fail if
they're just going after the car or
their house or you know the jet or
whatever it is it's like no you're not
it won't happen and I think will fail
and I think eventually there'll be more
businesses built on you know bailing
them out you know I have to be
empathetic to what you have up front
opportunity costs and other things like
I think there's a way I think there's a
lot of good stuff on the horizon I think
I believe your business you exact human
beings 40 years from now as things get
reframed the business was built from day
one to be able to afford to kick Dustin
out a weekend when you just decided no
way where is you know where is I'm just
and I maybe that is what you do but I
but I wouldn't never expect the business
to do that I do believe that we need to
reframe success
we have to make happy we have to for the
[ __ ] sake of so many [ __ ] millions
of people we have to make success
happiness we have to have to have to
have to we have to teach people how to
live very happily making eighty one
thousand dollars a year that is
controlling their expenses that is not
applying for credit cards that is not
valuing the clothes they wear and the
cars they drive we have to we have to
teach parents how to make their children
feel comfortable that they have a worse
car or you know things like we have to
teach that as an advantage like kids are
funny like I think you can educate kids
at seven or eight of like hey we have
less that is going to be your advantage
I believed it and and so others can too
we've just become very consumeristic
we've become very at the mercy of
opinion judgment as a is at an all-time
high
people are just judging people left and
right now because of the political
climate and they're they're crashing
because of it oh I don't think we've
even seen the crash
we are in a opioid and mental health
crisis and the economy is phenomenal
right does everybody understand what's
about to happen next
do you understand that only financial
success is holding up many as a last leg
and when that goes the hole I mean I
genuinely believe the mental carnage
that comes with the next economic
downturn is going to be far more extreme
than we can predict because the overlay
of depression is far greater than it was
in 1987 in 1998 in you know excuse me in
2008 in 2001 post 9/11 and the calm
bubble and all the other times it's
happened I'm very very very concerned
and hence my actions speak to that my
content has taken a fundamental shift
over the last two to three years because
I want to put my head on the pillow when
this all goes down to say I gave it my
best at-bat and very few people on earth
have spent the dollars and time to
create a communication infrastructure to
pump positivity with practicality at
scale to the level that I have on
[ __ ] earth I don't know anybody and
so I need to do that because I believe I
see what's about to happen and I can't
look the other way and look myself in
the mirror when it actually goes down
when I know I have it in me to be the
kind of communicator that can make a
positive impact right and if for by the
way I actually said this yesterday
filter Anto over dinner my friend and
business associate I said huh I'd never
thought about it and this is probably
why I just said what I just said because
how the subconscious works I have a
funny feeling that garyvee consumers
people that consume my content are gonna
be major winners during the next
downturn because they're going to
believe like I do
yeah that this adversity is good they're
going to enjoy going back to Rocky and
moving in with their parents and all
this they're going to put the process of
the rebuilding on a pedestal
while the far majority that haven't
consumed this perspective are gonna
think it's the worst thing that ever
happened well it's cuz it's built on a
false narrative I agree
they blew something that's absolutely
not true that's never gonna go away I
agree
okay we have a question so we're giving
away a case of empathy wine to one of
our listeners her name is chef Lizette
and this was it this is this is a part
of chef Lizette yes okay interacted with
every single piece of content of mine
over the last eight years okay so well
maybe you've heard this before so she
said you stated so smartly on a sports
podcast with Adam shine okay that you
believe the metrics for vetting incoming
football players should be based more on
emotional intelligence versus benchpress
or performance stats
what should the metrics or standards be
for putting social media influencers on
a pedestal what was the transition she
just made what what should the metrics
be or standards for putting social media
influencers on a pedestal
well definitely should not be following
count and that is what we currently
score on right you know I think we're
chef Lizette is going properly is I
believe in the gray not in the black and
white and the point I was making on
shinies podcast was now that I've been
in the football business for three years
I'm like whoa right there
you know maybe because football is my
one weird
place I never deployed my thought on the
world on football but now I have which
is oh right football is just like
everything I believe in I don't care
that you went to Harvard and you're good
at sales if you're a piece of [ __ ]
you're not gonna be good in my company
cuz you're gonna destroy everything
around you that's football I don't give
a [ __ ] if you run a three nine forty if
you're beating women if you [ __ ] hang
out with [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] if
you're a insecure dick in the locker
room and nobody likes you
I don't care how many [ __ ] touchdowns
you're gonna score inevitably that is
going to be a problem so um comma that's
what we need to do with social media
influencers or anybody else I believe
over time we will get far more
thoughtful around emotional intelligence
and I do believe that look I think I'm a
living proof of it my level of Fame
whatever it is is growing rapidly and
it's not because I'm so attractive or so
funny or so incredible in my athletics I
am bringing value to human beings which
results in admiration there are really
fancy people that I have dinners with
handlers at events that handle way more
famous people than me and they are
constantly taken aback by the
interactions I have with people who
stopped me in the halls at the airport
in life and to the point where some were
inevitably by the third interaction if I
take three selfies or have two
conversations they will literally and
again these are people who are
surrounded by the most famous people in
the world they will look at me and say
what's going on and I do not believe
they're saying I didn't realize how many
people knew you I think what they're
saying is why does this feel different
and I believe that admiration feels
different than liking somebody for
something vain yeah and I believe that
that will be scored long term impact and
how you make people feel and like you
know the quality of what you're putting
out into the world will continue to rise
I think subconsciously people know the
truth like you it resonates with a
person when they hear it and you're
everywhere with that truth that you so
passionately believe in and it just
resonates with us all
that's right and that's why the other
thing that people ask me about when I'm
in again I'm traveling enough and doing
enough events that people inevitably
will be with me for the day the partners
of the event or what have you and
they're completely flabbergasted by the
demo range you know a lot of people
think my audience is like young dudes
and then we'll be walking in the airport
or at the event and a 73 year old
african-american female will roll up in
a 55 year old old white guy or like you
know Latino you know nine-year-old from
ticked up like it's the truth is
universal okay okay so it is that brings
me to my next question it comes from Liv
my sales managers daughter watches you
out tick-tock and she heard that I was
interviewing you and she said to me the
other night in a party she said she
she's ten she said would you ask Gary a
question for me and I said sure what is
it so she had two questions one why do
you make videos and two what is your
favorite food right
this growth in the under 12 demos gave
me a lot of fun you get a lot of
favorite food favorite food is
definitely English peas so not snap peas
not you know not green beans there's
something called English peas yep they
were my complete obsession I love them
when they're in season
I'm like the happiest boy why do I make
videos I have an inherent want to share
goodness that I feel uncomfortably
grateful and almost borderline guilty in
having in my body it feel I used to hear
things like I have to or if you know my
body's making me you know when I was
here you know and I would always like
laugh and think that was such horseshit
like an you know like like from a
musician or you know an actor or actress
and I I understand now I had no interest
in anything remotely close to notoriety
or fame I was 34 years old before I'm 30
if she's me I was 31 years old before I
made a wine video and I was 34 years old
before I made a business video I didn't
move to LA and wait tables to be on
television I I worked in a liquor store
in New Jersey and as
the video this is where I do my now like
this is not super complicated the world
changed and gave me opportunity to
communicate and I and live I needed to
do it I had to do it it felt right what
I was doing for my inner circle and for
my acquaintances I now had an
opportunity to do at scale and the
admiration is intoxicating the attention
is cool I'm okay with it
but I'm not in LA I didn't if I was in
need of the attention I would have gone
for fame as a child right I the
admiration is intoxicating I genuinely
enjoy being admired and I don't even
know if that's like good or like kind of
like super not like weirdly selfish and
kind of like you know narcissist I don't
I don't I don't think so but but I'm
okay punch line is I'm okay say I've
never really heard anybody say it so I
almost don't know where it sits when
people hear me say I'm addicted to
admiration I see this good it means I'm
being held accountable to doing good
things because because I can't be
admired for making the most money as
long as you don't get high on it right
as long as I've gotten I've gotten more
sober on it I as I continue to gain
momentum I find myself going the other
way
I find myself trying to scrutinize
myself more I find myself trying to
share more of my my shortcomings or
inabilities I find myself over reacting
to making sure I say hello to everybody
or be thoughtful of and every and
utterly every interaction I I find
myself speaking to myself more saying
[ __ ] are you like do you understand that
you can die in an hour and nobody's
gonna give a [ __ ] in a week outside of
like seven to twelve of your family
members and then your inner circle a
little bit maybe you get a month out of
them but what like I the amount of times
I say to myself who the [ __ ] are you do
you understand that if you died right
now nobody's gonna give a [ __ ] is very
high
and I love that that I don't I don't see
that so yeah I don't think that's I
don't think that's dark I think that is
uh that's in an that's a counterbalance
conversation with myself that is
reacting to there's a lot going on with
me right now that and I'm aware of it
but I don't think that makes me special
I really don't I I think it makes my
parents special I think it makes my
circumstance special I feel like I'm
just the I feel like I'm a FedEx box I'm
like just the thing that's just
delivering it like I'm just the
container really I mean it
vaynermedia success I feel good about
I'm the architect but I feel like I'm
the product I'm the Pinocchio I was made
yeah and so it's hard for me when you're
like you're great I'm like I'm like [ __ ]
man I wish I made me instead of being me
yeah you know like that's why actually
this is funny
that's why me garish Vaynerchuk the
human strategist is much more proud
about what's happening with me than the
person that gets the attack like the
person me behind me
as I think about how and what I do like
because I set a strategy that I'm
actually really proud of not that people
are like you're you're so awesome right
so if you're coming from that place I
asked everybody to leave our audience
with one successful mind tip given that
you feel like you're just a channel for
that that your parents made you what
would you recommend everybody that's
listening is something that they could
do from a thinking perspective to go
optimism
practical optimism it's pulling from the
opposite directions this is my left and
right in America or getting torn apart
they're both right in different ways
there is absolutely no room for being
cruel or mean or suppressive to another
human being
period there's also a very dangerous
slope when you eliminate merit and
accountability it leads to entitlement
and delusion which leads to depression
so [ __ ] your 8th place trophies Brooklyn
right but [ __ ] you if your [ __ ] you
think you're better than somebody
because you they don't look like you
yeah like you're not from here [ __ ] you
know cruelty and no delusional practical
optimism you don't work it's highly
likely the thing you don't want the
thing you want to happen will not happen
like so but be optimistic like you know
optimism really matters like the
Internet is the playground not the
government not America not your parents
not schools not your job
we all have unlimited we have levels of
freedom that have never been seen before
sure I mean you can create an avatar
character if you think you're so
suppressed create a cartoon make an old
white man if he's got it so good by the
way that's a little another thing that
people need to understand the level of
depression and white males is just as
high as everybody else right like this
privileges mindset not what you look
like like the mindset game we and we'll
never we can see what we all look like
and so we can make judgment and that's
fine I'm not gonna be able to change
that but if you want to have a more
thoughtful conversation what's going on
in people's chemicals in their brain is
far more privileged than anything else
let er people make with thirty two
thousand dollars a year are a super
minority of minorities within this
country and are [ __ ] skipping and
whistling to happiness everyday and
there's [ __ ] a 41 year old white dude
with a [ __ ] benzo and a Ferrari and a
Lamborghini and a private plane and
making 33 million a year who's [ __ ]
doing drugs at night just to cope with
the deep inherent pain in his heart
that's the truth that's true and so you
know we got a lot of work to do but I
always think that times like this lead
to the bounce back I think we're on the
verge of a tremendous era in our society
that is going to be the reaction to a
lot of what's going on right now all the
tension in the air and I'm looking
forward to that I'm looking forward to
in my mid fifties through 60s to watch
our society prosper in its real efforts
to do more of the right collective thing
and I think that will only happen once
we have empathy and compassion to listen
instead of just yelling at each other
and judging and
what sucks awesome Gary thanks much for
doing this really appreciate it thank
you
[Music]
you